[Music]
this is StarTalk sports edition let me
bring on my co-host Gary O'Reilly Gary
how you doing hey Neil all right former
Soccer Pro from the UK and now retired
and yes serving as uh our part-time
announcer but you announce other you
actually still announce soccer games
don't you yeah yeah I get to pollute the
airwaves
okay and and tell tell people who are
much younger than me what they're doing
wrong and sometimes what they're doing
right so there you go there you go and
Chuck how you doing man I'm doing great
I do the same thing as Gary except
without Sports attached okay I just tell
young people what they're doing wrong
and why they suck
so Gary what did you cook up you and
your producers cook up for today all
right um we recently or you recently did
an explainer how fast can a car
accelerate
um and it triggered a lot of interest
and and you know real amount of interest
and our audience this is our this is our
spin-off just the 10 minute explainer
yeah 10-15 minutes explainer and it's
been it's been phenomenally successful
but this one really did sort of grab a
certain audience and they they were
asking you know get someone from Formula
One on get someone from Nascar on we
want to know everything that's going on
talk talk talk talk and um well FYI to
all of our audience we're working on
that so okay hopefully we'll have both
those boxes ticked in the coming months
so
stand by be ready um while we wait for
those to drop
um you're gonna pop the hood uh take a
look inside and find out how and why
cars are doing not to 16 under three
seconds which is Bonkers for me growing
up with things that did it in nine right
for Americans not mean zero okay yes
sorry yeah zero to sixteen but but first
I mean I suppose really in the classic
sense we need someone to come along and
kick the tires
so we found that person and that person
is Jason fenske
now if I pronounce that correctly
congratulations me if I haven't my
apologies Jason
um
um English isn't my first yes it is my
first language yes
um he's a mechanical engineer he's a
YouTube Car Guru I'll I'll explain it
that way and he is founder owner and
host of the engineering explained
Channel on YouTube and this channel is
so popular it's got a three and a half
million subscribers and has been on the
air for about the last 12 years so uh
Neil well wait so that's not even what's
impressive okay three and a half million
so what the total number of views to all
of his videos is more than 600 million
so we're talking serious serious access
into people's Gear Head ways in in the
world yeah most of that was one guy
without a life
Chuck speaks the truth
thank you I appreciate you having me
what I like here was the introduction of
the audience wanted someone from formula
one so we were to the bottom of the
barrel and found this guy
we've got these things in the pipeline
Jason so yeah keep our audience waiting
any longer so yeah I don't think that I
think his point was
um your intro sucked
no no no no no no I don't think it put
me in my deserved place
yeah no no oh no we're joking all right
so so here's the thing I put out a a
what we call an explainer video which is
random stuff in our civilization that I
think could benefit from highlighting
the physics that's going on in it and
one of them was you know what's the
maximum uh a car can accelerate under
sort of normal conditions and when you
do that with sort of a frictional
coefficient of one and which is rubber
on concrete or asphalt which is a very
high friction level there you come up
with more than three seconds but not
much more and yet we realize that
there's some cars that are doing better
than that and the only way I understand
that from my physics background is that
the car is somehow attaching itself to
the road and going beyond the
coefficient of friction of one maybe
getting more than one as a coefficient
of friction as from a dead stop uh 0 to
60 acceleration so we're trying to find
out here from you yes is that right were
my calculations correct and what is the
future of this sort of acceleration
crown that is currently owned by my
record show here a Tesla 2021 s
I think is current fastest and I like
your calculation methodology here I
think it's very cool and yes if you look
at like okay if you have one G if you
have one gravity pulling down on that
car that's your max Excel right up for
over three seconds right right yes that
gives you like something like 2.7
seconds I believe it is as you're like
theoretical limit and yet we know it's
possible to beat that not only because
it's done but like you can look at a car
and say okay we have cars that have
decelerated from 60 miles per hour to
zero in less than 100 feet and so that
means the average acceleration or
deceleration in this case is greater
than one G they're they're doing what
seems impossible so what what you
described is correct in that way wait
that can happen if you crash into a wall
yeah
but we're doing this we're doing this
purely with tires oh oh okay okay I got
you gotcha slow down with tires all
right gotcha gotcha yes all right I mean
the reverse is true also right like you
can put a rocket on the back of a car
and then you're no longer limited by
tires in your acceleration correct but
as far as street legal tires are are
today's limit is about two seconds
um car companies have said they've beat
that uh they're lying because there's
this old industry standard of how we
test 0-60 that actually starts at like
six miles per hour so it's nonsense
so you get up you're really getting a
rolling start yeah yeah yes exactly and
that's what it's called it's called
rollout and you get everyone deletes the
first foot and says the first foot
doesn't count uh and the first book
should count if it's a zero to sixty if
it's a six to sixty all right fine
um yeah yeah plus Jason your timings
here are to the hundredth of a second so
these things matter yes right yes we
have in 2.06 seconds the Ferrari uh left
Ferrari sf90 at 2.1 sec
Turbo S lightweight 2.24 seconds so and
likely these numbers you're seeing are
with rollout deducted so the real number
would be about 0.2 to 0.3 seconds longer
than what those numbers say
um so for example when this Tesla got
the record and they said it was like
1.99 seconds the actual time was like
2.3 seconds and they were like we broke
two seconds and it's like that is but
it's cool it's still cool I just got to
tell you that that's kind of like an
a-hole Elon Musk Here Comes an Elon joke
okay yeah I feel it coming go on get it
out of your system God that was it I'm
just saying that's out of your system
seems so very Elon you know what I mean
he's not the in his defense
yes exactly Porsche doesn't do it so
Props to Porsche like we can direct
positive uh Vibes towards Porsche for
doing it right wait wait wait stop stop
the presses
I started calling it Porsche
when I grew up it was a horse
no no it was a black girl in Chicago
what does it Shakespearean
foreign
when your audience is car enthusiasts
you get berated anytime you say anything
just slightly incorrect so I have been
trained to say Porsche because I guess
that's how they say it in Germany and uh
so so yeah that's how I'll continue to
say it they all right all right so how
mad how mad was Ferrari that Tesla beat
them in a series of 60. that's gotta
piss them off oh yeah and it's
interesting too because it's like you
can spend three million dollars on a car
or you can spend a hundred thousand
dollars on a car and they both hit 60 in
the same amount of time like that's a
bummer right like that's how electric
cars have really brought uh the price
disparity down from performance I didn't
I didn't make that announcement so of
course the Tesla's electric the Ferrari
is hybrid and the Porsche was an
internal combustion so it was actually
comparing three different kinds of
Motors here right yes all right so Jason
how do you what do you how are you
cheating to beat the the acceleration of
1G what are you doing to arrive at that
yeah so I I think it's a it's a it's an
interesting question and it's like it's
difficult
I don't know I guess it's a good answer
but if you think about like how does a
tire work like how does a gear work for
example a gear works by by meshing
within a Groove and you can push against
that right and a Tire Works in a similar
way where it meshes into the road so it
can push laterally against the road uh
whether that's for decelerating
accelerating cornering whatever you can
exceed you know that 1G if you were to
just assume a perfectly smooth surface
one sitting on the other that's how it
is no no no we can't I don't I don't see
how you can exceed 1G if it's one smooth
rubber on any other smooth surface
unless it's gummy and it's still so so
in other words if you had a textured
surface then like you said the gears
then the rubber can dig into the texture
yes and then push off of it the way
gears would and then you're not limited
to the friction at that point okay but
when you when you want that texture to
be on the road and not on the tire
correct because if the tire is
completely flat and the road is texture
then you get the road digging into the
tire but if the tire is textured and the
road is flat or even textured you don't
get as much uh grabbing I don't think it
matters as long as one intersects the
other right but Jason that's why we have
you here talking exactly but like so the
rubber is soft right the road is hard so
the rubber is the one that kind of goes
into the grooves of the roads the
rubbers the road's very rough surface
you have you know softer rubber gives
you a better lot and so you have that
rubber sink into the road and then you
know it propels you forward like a like
a gear could if it was a gear sitting on
you know a like a pinion
um rack and pinion type system where the
wheel is you know the pinion and the
rack is on the ground and then you
accelerate using that gear just using
rubber instead of a gear in in that rack
so the best uh case scenario would be to
go zero to 60 on tires made of chewing
wait wait Jason so the sorry Gary I
gotta get this out so so are they doing
this on the same track
have Nicks and dings in it and are they
using the same rubber tires because if
none of those are the same then we're
not comparing which car can accelerate
we're not right it's all silly it's all
for hubris right like that's why we do
these comparisons
um Chucky's kind of right about the
chewing gum thing and that in Drag Races
they will actually like spray down
essentially glue so that when you launch
your tire is sitting on this glue right
at the very start so you get a really
good start so that is done and that is
the way that Tesla says that they got
their 1.98 second or whatever it was and
so it's like okay it was done on a drag
strip you deleted some time and you used
glue it's like so once you put all these
into like context it's like well you can
just take a drag Tire which is much more
capable than street tires and you can
beat two seconds all day long
they also use the Ferrari
so what we're discussing we did all
right Elon Musk has become Dick
Dastardly out of Wacky Races right so if
there's nothing he can't do he won't do
to cheat but I don't understand that
sentence say that do you know they see
the animation wacky racing Wacky Races
oh yeah okay okay
no no that's fine you were too busy
being scientific okay thanks for wasting
our time in front of the TV obviously so
okay Jason before we get to the rubber
on the on the surface
what between uh an electric motor and an
internal combustion engine is different
that makes this thing go put so much
power and energy in there that can do
this sort of speed so what's the
difference really there what's going on
fundamentally there's a different energy
source right like a battery versus a
fuel tank but as far as how they
accelerate I think there's there's two
key differences between a combustion
engine and an electric motor the
electric motor in how they behave I
should state so the electric motor is
going to have torque immediately so uh
it it starts out it's torque curve at
zero it's basically Peak torque and it
remains that way until you're limited in
power so you get all of your torque
immediately right at the beginning when
the core isn't moving a combustion
engine requires a certain RPM so it has
to rev up to a certain RPM in order to
reach that Peak torque so you you have a
delay there in when uh not only when you
are able to reach your maximum
acceleration but also dual lay and when
you ask for it versus when you receive
it so that's the second difference being
the response of an electric motor hey I
want these electrons to move they do
that very quickly the response of a
combustion engine I want this air that's
in an intake to then go into a cylinder
get pulled down get compressed explode
you're asking for that to happen and of
course that can't be an instant process
so as far as response and then it's got
to turn the Piston which goes to the
crankshaft which goes to the thing which
goes to the wheel all that's got exactly
yes it's a long process so when you
press that pedal down whichever go pedal
it is gas or electric uh the electric
one is going to respond so much quicker
than the gas one because so many more
things have to happen for that
combustion uh to start happening and to
react to what you asked it to do one
thing electricity is really good at is
rotating things so
that's you know that's what turbines are
that's what just rotate that's all it
wants to do and that's what it does best
so whereas gasoline you gotta like you
need your Rube Goldberg device to end up
turning your wheels at the end of that
yeah end of that path right yeah which
is reciprocating motion to create
circular motion with combustion engines
versus circular motion to create
circular motion with electric motors
exactly perfectly worded perfectly
worded the rotary engine does exist and
Mazda didn't just bring it back in
Europe commercial
which by the way no one bought into like
I remember that they were like it's a
rotary engine and America was like so
what well yeah yeah okay so describe
tell us about the Wankel engine
well uh the one of the big flaws is that
it burns oil by Design so you actually
inject oil into the combustion chamber
where this rotary is spinning
um but it's very different in that uh
traditional engine you have a piston
that moves up and down uh you have four
strokes and that gives you your
combustion process you still have these
four cycles and a rotary engine intake
compression power exhaust but it's all
done with this little Dorito that spins
inside of a housing and so it has
rotational motion so it's a three-sided
rotating thing a Dorito
you mentioned food that's it Chuck's
going to be gone for a while now because
mine's gonna wander and now he's
interested in it again I never knew I
like rotary engines until just now okay
I have to give a geopolitical historical
fact here if I make this a public
service announcement uh the Wankel
engine I remember when Mazda introduced
it the big selling point was a big
selling point was that it had one third
or two-thirds fewer parts
fewer moving Parts yes than a regular
engine which meant it would not break
down as often and in a world where cars
broke down this was a highly desired
feature right that was before cars even
internal combustion engine cars were so
reliable that no one is worried in the
morning but Jason I don't know how old
you are but I'm old enough to remember
there was a chance every morning that
your car might not start
there was a chance okay and you did not
always know if you'd get to work on time
in your own car so this was a selling
point at a time when car engines
basically fail cars would be on the side
of the road with the hood open that
doesn't happen anymore so if if that's
no longer a selling point why would
anyone want a Wankel engine that's my
question back to you Jason well okay
well
um I think like uh the Enthusiast spirit
is probably the the real answer of like
why someone might want it today
unfortunately they brought it back as a
range extender so I don't think that's
what people were looking for okay but
more miles per gallon okay yeah yes
exactly so basically just to generate
electricity uh the advantage modest
defense is its size so they're very
compact because you have three chambers
where combustion uh is basically this
this four-stroke cycle is occurring in
three separate places at any given time
whereas in a you know a piston cylinder
engine if you have one cylinder you have
one place where that's happening so you
can have really good power density
meaning that the engine can be very
small and compact that's its biggest
Advantage
um it has admission emissions
disadvantages up until this point maybe
Mazda has created some tricks for the
one that's coming out um but yeah there
aren't there aren't there are huge
upsides to it returning other than it's
cool you lost me at wanker that's the
problem there's an L on me
never let the truth get in the way of it
that's different
Tomatoes we gotta take a quick break
when we come back uh we're gonna talk to
Jason about is there anything that's
limiting the top speed of cars at all
when we come back with our special guest
Jason fenske on StarTalk sports edition
we're back StarTalk sports edition today
we are not up in the hood we are under
the hood hey
caught me by surprise
okay so we we're we're up under the hood
uh with Jason fenske and Jason you have
a whole platform uh engineering
explained could just give us a minute
tell us what that is
sure so the idea started back when I was
in college
um about 12 years ago and I'm majoring
in
majoring in mechanical engineering there
you go I thought I'd go for it I thought
I might actually learn something about
cars uh while I was getting this major
and I didn't I just did a bunch of math
problems so that was kind of
disappointing so I created this platform
which was basically taking the
intimidation out of cars
um from an engineering standpoint
they're they're very complicated so the
platform essentially is how do cars work
from an engineering standpoint uh in a
bunch of videos
um just kind of breaking it down to bite
size uh digestible pieces of information
I love it I love it a very popular
YouTube destination with like a zillion
viewers uh views of all of the uh all of
the videos we're not at a billion yet so
I don't think I can say a zillion but it
would be okay
some number bigger than you remembered
to say but yeah when you get a when you
hit a billion come back here we'll teach
you how to say the word yeah
all right so so Jason tell us
tell us what uh wait I don't think you
answered me from the first segment
um I do that is there some
sure of the track or was it glue they
sprayed on the tires only for that two
second acceleration compare comparison
um where all three cars the the Tesla
the Ferrari and the uh Porsche were
coming in at around two seconds why
don't they just
improved why don't they just dig grooves
into the track
yeah that would just make it a train
so like the the big companies that do
this testing aside from you know the the
brands themselves like Car and Driver
Motor Trend the big names in in doing
these tests they do things consistently
so they have their one track that they
do it at they apply atmospheric weather
corrections to their numbers
um they so there is a there is a
standard in place so that you can say
this is fair to compare these two you're
on different tires so that alone like
means they're gonna have differences
right it's whatever Tire the car company
chose to put on them
um and some some companies will be you
know a little mischievous here and say
like we offer this tire
um and it as like the Sports Package so
they can get these good numbers and then
realistically they want you to get a
different tire or something like that
right right or more Road Friendly Tire
from for your life yeah I think for in
the example with Tesla they picked the
track where they said it had to be done
at they said it needed to use this glue
they wouldn't let Motor Trend do it
their own facility until later our Motor
Trend argued enough and that eventually
they let them do it
um yeah and then they got different
numbers and that's where the real number
of 2.3 comes from okay so do we all know
or you may have paid attention uh it
started maybe 15 years ago on off ramps
that have a sharp curve there are
grooves in the road
that enable the car to that prevent the
car from sliding off into the railing on
the outer edge of that turn and those
grooves came from NASA
when they wanted to make sure the space
shuttle when it landed because it
doesn't it's it lands with no engine
right so it's just parachutes and some
brakes so it can't reverse the thrust of
the engine to slow down so space shuttle
runways are very long they wanted to
make sure that this shuttle wouldn't
Drift from Crosswinds or anything so
they grooved it upon learning how
effective that was that became part of
our road design for wow exits that where
you're coming from high speed and you
have to get to low speed my question to
you Jason is I thought it was just lazy
Road I didn't even know this but now I'm
going to get a question about it yeah so
now just check it out and and somewhere
there's been a risk from before there
are these grooves so the rubber cannot
slide sideways against it easily all
right you will not skid sideways uh when
you have grooves because the rubber is
digging in just like you said earlier
Jason with the gearing the question to
you is if you make a speed track where
those grooves are now sideways to you
okay they're not in the direction you're
going there at right angles now the
entire can dig in like grooves of a of a
of a gear and now you could sky's the
limit in the acceleration it would seem
to you're right you're right I think
that would work I didn't know about the
groups thing I had always thought it was
just a wear thing because I guess some
vehicles have different track widths
um so it would be difficult to say this
is the set Groove for everyone but
you're absolutely right about the tire
thing and in fact in off-road tires so
with with most tires that are come on
our cars the tread is all basically on
the outside of that tire the part that
touches the ground on off-road tires
you'll see that tread come down on the
side of the sidewall and so the reason
for that is because off-road you may be
coming up to a rock and so you know that
rock has let's say a 90 degree angle you
want to use all the grip you have so
you'll use both contact surfaces whether
it's the right side of the tire or
beneath the tire to climb I've never
thought about it do something very
similar with grooves in a track okay
that's just which is what it was just a
straight line when you look at those
YouTube videos you it looks like these
these off-road trucks are Spider-Man
they're literally climbing up rocks
right right my sister has a car that can
do that right it's each each wheel can
be independently not only suspended as
just that's easy but they can also turn
differently I mean it's it's it's yeah
they all have steering individually they
all have steering right now it is alive
you know wow all right so Jason I'm
finally rested on the acceleration
questions so now let me ask you
um why are how come no one's going 300
miles an hour on a race track what's
going on there have we not so
um I guess maybe we haven't I think
there's a few car companies that have
products that say it can be done
um hit 300. yeah I think I think Bugatti
did he hit 300 I don't want to say
things and yeah it's going to look
poorly now no matter what because I
don't know uh but I think Bugatti did do
it they they have the capability uh
there's a few other cars out there that
are capable and essentially it's a power
question
um uh and not a tire question which is
kind of fun you're you're limited by
aerodynamic drive so however much power
you put in your car and however small
you make it the smaller you make it the
less drag it's gonna have the more
aerodynamic you make it the less drag
it's gonna have and then tell us how are
you giving tell us how drag scales with
velocity
so the force of drag is uh the equation
has velocity squared in it power is
force times velocity so power is
velocity cubed uh so when it comes to
aerodynamic drag the force coming
against you uh is increasing with a
squared exponent uh as you reach higher
speed so it's very difficult to overcome
you need a lot more power each time you
want to go a little bit faster
yeah so so in other words so the air
resistance against you is significant at
high speeds and practically ignorable at
low speeds is that a fair statement
there yes yes exactly so and like with
zero to 60 times
um one thing that you can use to help in
acceleration is downforce but you don't
have that at low speeds because you
don't really have much aerodynamic drag
there's nothing helping to push your car
down on the ground because you could use
downforce to theoretically have greater
acceleration if you have a big Force
pushing your car down then that means
the amount of grip you have is greater
and thus you can accelerate faster is it
is it cheating to draft a car above
that's above the speed
oh I don't I don't think they allow it
as far as like if you say you got the
record and you were just you know behind
a 747
[Laughter]
by the way I I told you I said the story
in one other episode I'm going to say it
again uh I had a car where you could see
what your instantaneous miles per gallon
was all right yes all cars can do that
right most today can so I was always
fascinated by that what was my miles per
gallon as I went uphill well was it as I
was going horizontal yes that was
downhill obviously the miles per gallon
goes up very high and I see let me try
something and I took the car and I drove
I would say dangerously close I don't
recommend this at home to uh 18 wheeler
truck
and as I got closer and closer I'm on a
level road now and I was getting 24
miles per gallon which was the
advertised sort of Highway uh mileage
for this car as I got closer
it then said 28 miles per gallon 30 35
50 100 Infinity
when I was within 12 feet of the of the
back door of the of the car that you
created a perpetual motion machine it
was like holy I'm I'm using no
energy right now but now I can't just
you know text my friend to tell them
that because I'll die if the truck stops
short but it was uh that drafting is is
something I mean that's very real
phenomenal yes you know a similar
comparison if you think about wake
surfing so a boat is going along and
you're surfing the wake of that boat
you're using no energy right you're not
using anything to propel you you're
using the energy of the vehicle in front
of you so that truck can have a wake
behind it of this like suction because
it's punching this giant hole in the air
and then it's creating this suction
behind it perhaps some of that suction
could even be pulling you uh meaning
yeah your your energy use could be could
be zero uh if you had the perfect design
and I would add that many people don't
get this right and you probably see this
Jason that when you draft off of someone
else
you make them more efficient
you're not yes exactly they say get off
my back I don't want to drag you no
you're not no you're not I'm making you
more aerodynamic by coming behind and
disrupting the vacuum right that would
otherwise be pulling you backwards this
is
tailgating I think what we're going to
do right now is create a dangerous
precedence for drivers to just like
screw that gas is hot yes
okay Jason go back to the the electric
vehicles for the time being
I mean we've seen it on in combustion
engine
man when I need to make this thing go
faster and vented the turbo
is there such a thing that you can bring
into an electric motor that has a
similar effect because if we're talking
about cars that
go fast we are looking mainly at
electric vehicles now well don't confuse
acceleration yeah so celebration but now
we need to top now we need to get a top
speed up for for these sort of things
are we do you how is there an equivalent
for the
turbo I like this question uh yeah and
and my initial thought about it is no
but but they're they're still kind of a
way right like
um
the question is can you get more power
out of out of a motor and and you can
with electric motors just like you can
with uh you know combustion engines
um it's simply a matter of heat and
eventually that heat means the device
fails whether it's a combustion engine
or an electric motor I think the answer
to your question as it relates to
Electric cores is a bigger battery
because basically what happens with
batteries is that there is a certain
discharge rate which we say is
acceptable whatever that may be uh and
so if you have a small battery
on a per cell basis that one individual
cell there's a maximum limit of power
that can go out of it so if you have
more cells that means there's a greater
maximum power so simply the size of the
battery here so that is why
today it is yes it is literally
what a battery the word battery means
it's like a series of these cells right
we need to have a battery of armor it's
it's a so that is the we think a battery
as a Duracell right but it is literally
the sequence of these cells go on I have
to slip that in there yeah go ahead yes
no that's very fair so the more of these
you have which is why you see cars like
you know the Tesla or the Porsche ticon
or the Lucid air uh hitting these
records it's because they have massive
battery packs you won't see a small
battery vehicle hitting these giant
numbers and the reason is the battery is
too small so it doesn't have as much
power to discharge
um so it's it's very different from like
a fuel tank because no one goes oh the
size of my fuel tank is huge like no one
cares whatever you can drive far cool
that doesn't impact how much power you
can make how much power you can make is
impacted by how quickly you can put that
fuel into your engine
now we're jacking the white top now now
I know there's not enough carry he's
getting there go okay well
it is it's disappointing because there's
not this small single device like a
turbo that you throw in and you know
suddenly you're making 50 more power
it's like you can you can tune uh the
the battery to to go to a higher
discharge rate and you can put more
power in your motor it doesn't mean that
will be reliable it doesn't mean your
things will last as long but it can be
done
um above like you know there's there's
limits uh that we say this is safe and
it will last us two hundred thousands I
got to bring Gary's question back in so
the point is what you're saying is I can
go faster all other things being equal
if I have a bigger battery because then
I have more energy to draw from however
however now I'm going really fast but
I'm in the in the in a very high air
resistance regime and yes B the mass of
the car is huge now yes is there some
Plateau where there's no faster speed an
electric car can go because the battery
have to be too damn large
that's a great question I don't know
what the limit would be but but I mean I
think it would be quite High because you
can just think about something that's
very long and narrow right like a train
like if if you have the space to do it
uh I think putting practical limits on
that question could make it fun if you
have the space to do it like there's so
much energy you can put in a battery and
you you can make it really long and and
so you could have this absurd number
that could happen but like that would
happen on city streets uh you know
within a mile of distance yeah then it
becomes a much more fun question
so is this a challenge Now for car
designers for unless it's battery
designers in in that are separate from
the college designers themselves not
really because think about it right now
I mean what's the top speed on these
electric cars yeah like it's a buck
whatever yeah you know like how much
more do you want to I mean how much
faster do you really want a car to go
Chuck how many people you think are
asking that question right now I want
this thing to go faster what what what
municipality what what government is
going to say oh yeah bring your bring
your 300 mile an hour you know electric
car mass produced that and put it on the
street
Germany Germany
the left lane you got me I forgot about
that that's fine let's be honest they
are Germans they're very restricted
people okay
let's be clear they're the only people
on Earth that you can give no speed
limit and they actually respect the fact
that there's no speed limit
I mean okay so that Chuck raises an
excellent point though in that I think
realistically if you were to ask someone
who drove let's say one of these
insanely fast uh electric cars do you
want it to be faster they might want it
to be lighter they might want it to
handle better but I don't necessarily
think they're gonna say oh I yeah it
wasn't quick enough for me it's like
this is as quick as it gets and keep in
mind no one mentioned this that at some
level it's not how fast you can go does
the car still maneuver at those speeds
right can you exactly do things in those
260 miles an hour but it doesn't turn it
doesn't turn yeah straight line and the
only way to stop the brakes won't work
because they're not hard see the thing
is for me now is it not then top speed
that we is now we are now calling our
Holy Grail for EVS is it I need to I
need this thing to go cross-country I
Need A Thousand Miles
yeah I got to tell you Neil has a very
cool uh electric vehicle and the first
time I was in it he scared the bejesus
out of me I'm still trying to rub the
brown stains off
I've never listen I ride motorcycles and
it's the closest thing to a motorcycle
acceleration that I've ever experienced
yeah it was there for you it's just
there it's it's always there yeah guys
we gotta take a print break when we come
back in the third segment uh Jason
finnske will tell us what is the future
of fuel an energy that's going to drive
us on the countryside or on the
racetrack we're in Star talk sports
edition continues
we're back StarTalk sports edition this
one is up under the hood
how do cars work how do engines work
we've got Jason fenske from engineering
explained it's an entire universe an
entire culture he built around his
expertise in mechanical engineering and
his interest in cars which is a
beautiful place to hang out especially
if you're a car geek as so many people
are so Jason I want to just sort of lead
off with just a reflection on some a bit
of physics history so for the longest
while we had the steam engine it was
great and the first automobiles had
steam engines in them all right of
course they would why wouldn't they yeah
before the internal combustion engine
was was perfected by I guess Carl Benz
but my point here is people said I got
an engine I can convert chemical energy
into kinetic energy why don't I make an
airplane out of this okay so they
started trying to design airplane Lanes
with steam engines
and they found out that steam engine
just weren't powerful enough so they
said let's build a bigger steam engine
and so they build a bigger steam engine
what are they doing their heating coal
or wood it boils water the water
evaporates creates a steam pressure that
drives a turbine or drives whatever it
is you need it to drive the point is
that steam engines
that were powerful enough to fly an
airplane
made the airplane too heavy to fly
period and it was it was this weird
frustrating fact
and I'm Langley in fact has whole books
attempting to fly using steam engines
and this didn't work and plan B didn't
work and there he is scratching his head
and it was not until the internal
combustion engine which got a lot of
energy in a small volume could then be
uplifted by the Wright brothers into the
right flyer and that gave us airplanes
and so I I'm just fascinated Jason when
you describe the fact that yeah if you
want to make your electric car go faster
just give it a bigger battery and at
some point I'm saying that's not going
to work you're going to top out but
anyway no it's absolutely true
historical note there but let's continue
this Jason what's the future of fuel
here what are we talking about
yeah so I think like let's take this um
if you think about airplanes and you
brought up airplanes and it's a great
point it's very difficult to have
commercial flight today uh using
electric power because energy density is
not there jet fuel puts a ton of energy
into a very small amount of space not
much weight uh electric car batteries
are massive they're super heavy and they
don't have that much energy to to give
people an idea
um say take a modern Tesla with a 100
kilowatt hour battery pack that's about
three gallons of gasoline so this is an
object that weighs over a thousand
pounds and it has the energy equivalence
of about three gallons of gas in other
words about 20 pounds of gas that's a
huge difference right now electric cars
are way more efficient so there's an
advantage there and that when they come
when they uh when gasoline combusts
you're at maybe 33 efficiency if you're
doing well you know an electric motor
can be at 95 efficiency so you can
triple your efficiency but you still
have to have this giant object so let's
just say that another way it's going to
be wait just to say that another way so
you have the same energy in an electric
battery and in your three gallons of gas
the three legs like you said weighs 20
pounds the the the battery weighs a
thousand pounds how yeah ever you'll get
many more miles out of those thousand
pounds for the same amount of energy in
the battery than you would have out of
the gasoline yes just because of the
efficiency of the motor yeah okay gotcha
yes exactly which is why we don't have
three gallon gasoline cars right and
there are 12 15 20 gallons so you can
actually Drive Motorcycles how big is a
motorcycle tank three is that's three
yeah those are small yeah
yeah okay go on so as far as as far as
hey can we solve this airplane problem
without using gasoline
um there are ways to do it hydrogen is
one fuel which we can use and we're
experimenting with cars there's been
production cars that use hydrogen uh I
believe actually uh maybe I'm wrong on
that statement but but I don't know
you're right you're right I didn't fuel
cell as far as like the Mirai the fuel
cells and then yeah Honda Clarity uh and
so then from hydrogen there's also
another step you can take because
hydrogen itself is not very dense so if
we go back to our analogy up we've got
three gallons of gas we've got you know
a thousand pounds of battery one gallon
of gasoline stored the way we store
hydrogen today which is like as a high
pressure gas it's about we need about
seven gallons of hydrogen so you still
need a lot of space hydrogen is very
light that's a good thing but it takes
up a huge amount of space so you know if
you have a 10 gallon tank in your car
you now need a 70 gallon tank to go the
same distance you need a bubble butt you
need a bubble butt on your car yeah
hydrogen is also very flammable I was
going to say isn't it yeah is the
hydrogen going to lead to a you know a
car that's basically you name oh the
humanity no no
Manatee
but yeah Jason hydrogen is flammable but
so is gasoline so what's the cut off
here
well the trade-off is that oh and it's
actually on this is my my whiteboard uh
combustion on hydrogen but as you burn
uh hydrogen with oxygen your only
emissions is water so H2O
so that's the big advantage in that you
don't have CO2 produced as a byproduct
of this combustion product
um so yeah there there's that's the
advantage and it's it's hydrogen more
volatility than gasoline I mean because
the meal brings up a great point they're
both combustible so is yes is one more
volatile
um
they're they're I don't know the answer
to that question uh do you want to test
it in a comments I can't tell you I'll
tell you I'll tell you so if you have a
a a a a a basin of gasoline and you toss
in a match uh it'll first light the
vapors all right because there's a lot
of gasoline oxygen mixture there and
then the top of the gasoline will just
burn whereas if you light a balloon
filled with hydrogen the whole thing
explodes instantly yes
by the way so do you remember Indiana
Jones where he's at the Nazi base camp
in the desert and he gets into the fight
with that Angelus guy yes and and the
gasoline spills and then it ignites at
one end right well and then it works its
way it works this way all the way
through to the table if that was a line
of hydrogen the whole thing would just
explode all at once oh that would have
been a terrible scene yeah yeah
people car enthusiasts in particular
like to look at hydrogen as a solution
that is not electric cars
um and another big challenge with it as
we're talking about this volatility here
is that you have these tanks and they're
at 10 000 PSI that is what it is stored
at in order to get enough hydrogen into
a you know small enough space that it
becomes useful again we're still in
rocket launches we don't it's not even
about the pressure it's about cooling it
so they cool the hydrogen yes until it
liquefies Now liquid hydrogen is way
denser than any gaseous hydrogen yeah
even at high pressure but the the rocket
is plugged in to to freezer uh yes
um elements elements right until it's
ready to launch so that yes so BMW
that's why there's ice falling off of it
in Florida remember you see the ice fall
off on a launch that's why yep that's
why this is happening so so go on
so BMW actually did this they had a
liquid hydrogen car called the hydrogen
7 in like 2007 uh the challenge is as
it's sitting in your garage of course
that hydrogen starts to rise in
temperature right so even though they
had this really well insulated uh fuel
tank eventually you have to let that
fuel out so they said in about 12 days
you can you lose your whole fuel tank
which like we don't want that right yeah
that's by the way I remember when they
were parading that around and they
gifted me I think it's actually in my
office I have a a one
um a half liter canister of water and it
says BMW exhaust and from when they were
parading around that that seven because
that was it was based on their on their
Model Seven I think what a great
marketing yes yes yeah yeah so I mean
okay Jason we we've we've gone through
hydrogen and we're kind of like coming
up with a whole load of nose yes as this
is yes so there must have there must be
this between situation but there's
another fuel is it the biofuels I mean
Formula One racing is going sustainable
with its fuels yes yeah so yeah we're
looking at 2026 they're going to have
all sustainable fuels in their hybrid
racing cars and I think by 2030 they're
hoping he says that there'll be carbon
neutral by 2030. okay so these will be
this so this will be formula two not
Formula One
oh thank you so I mean I mean with
sustainable foods are we at this uh flux
capacity so DeLorean so are we just
gonna be doing trash we can do it we can
essentially make gasoline
um we can take hydrogen we can take CO2
we can do some fancy chemistry and we
can create gasoline without ever having
taken anything you know out from the
ground as far as fossil fuels the
challenge is it's very expensive and it
takes a lot of energy right so for a
racing series like formula one that's no
problem right they can spend fifty
dollars a gallon and they're not gonna
care Porsche has said recently that they
think their current price per gallon of
uh you know a synthetic fuel that's made
using these processes it's about forty
dollars a gallon
yeah exactly so it's like we can say
this and if we can get it cheap
um great but you have to think about
theoretical limits like right like
there's a certain amount of energy
required to create that fuel and that
will always be greater than if you were
to just take that energy and put it in a
battery and then move the car right so
there are processes maybe like airplanes
where hey we don't have the capacity to
carry all this weight maybe we should go
the synthetic route even though it's
less efficient from a total energy
standpoint it's green so that's great we
didn't have you know net emissions from
it but right it's very challenging at
the risk of stating the obvious the the
oil in the ground is other than the cost
to extract it is basically free energy
nature sitting there Nature Made that
energy density in the oil right and you
take it out and it's ready to use so uh
so interesting you say that Jason that
we have the ability to basically make
gasoline but it takes more energy than
the energy you'd get out of the gasoline
you made so it would happen the sun made
that oil but the sun is also available
to us at all times and I think the real
uh um path forward is batteries and
solar together so you know some some
some means of sustaining and increasing
the the gain of a battery then you know
then burning something this public
service announcement brought to you by
Chuck Nice
you know how I feel about fossil fuels
how I feel about fossil fuels before we
get to Chuck's solution there's ethanol
e-fuels I mean yeah what about all that
what about all that yeah so where are
where where are we using them because
they're used in Formula One and in
IndyCar but they use different uh e
fuels one is an E10 one is an E85
so yes what are what are the you know
does this produce Chanel Number Five
product or water or what does it do
these are challenging because if you if
you look at what the people who make it
say you know one perspective they say
this is 60 of the emissions uh talking
about ethanol coming from corn here this
is 60 of the missions as gasoline so
it's still a significant amount though a
significant savings you know according
to the best case of the industry that
creates it if you look at studies that
have been done on what are the actual
emissions some say it's equal if not
higher than gasoline and and so there's
this spectrum of okay maybe at best we
do what a 40 Improvement using
corn-based ethanol there are better
Solutions you don't have to use corn you
can use all kinds of different things
sugar is much better than corn anyway
but yes all kinds of lobbying issues
there because America makes corn we
don't make sugar yes yes exactly so
we're starting from a problematic point
because we've decided corn must be the
way America does it and unfortunately
it's not the best way to do it uh the
emissions will always be greater than
other Solutions
all right we got to land this plane or
oh before we discover before we do
there's something that's kind of a itch
I need to scratch here we talk about
batteries we talk about how we're going
to make them lighter how they can store
more how they can do this how we can
weigh less Etc
but what are we doing with disposal
because these things are packed full of
rarest minerals right and we're going to
just tip them into a landfill site and
walk away because we solving one problem
while we create another so where are we
going forward with this sorry to sort of
did you sound like you're blaming Jason
for it man no no no no no no
yeah
Justin Jason what's up man
no I think I think it's a great point
and I feel like it should be discussed
more and I feel like it's one of those
things where it's just like oh like we
can ignore that uh because Evie is so
new and we don't have an insane quantity
of dead EV battery pack just sitting
there useless right
um I don't I don't know from a chemistry
standpoint if there are super hard
changes that occur within the battery
but to the best of my knowledge the all
the elements are still in there right
yeah I think so it's fair currently
mostly a matter of cost uh is is it
worth doing and we like to historically
do things based purely on cost and
disregard any other factors and you can
put shift the cost to the environment
and say well the environment got screwed
but I saved a dollar so I I would prefer
to see that we do this the right way
right and we recycle all of the uh and I
don't think again it's it's that easy to
just throw your electric car battery in
the truck I was gonna say just pick it
up as this scales I think what we'll see
is that battery collection and battery
recycling becomes a business and an
industry in itself and when the profit
yes presents itself in that industry
those problems will almost take care of
themselves because somebody will be
making money even if it is the actual
battery company manufacturers but
somebody whether it's a secondary Market
or the battery manufacturers themselves
or the end user in terms of recouping
costs somebody's going to make money
somewhere and that's where you'll see
incentives yes because it's nice city
council
well you can think of that battery as
like a concentrated solution of all the
elements you need to make batteries so
from that standpoint it's like this is
very valuable it has all the stuff that
I want and there are small companies
today that are doing this process and
trying to split the minerals and then
reselling them and one other point that
was left unnoted that we we seem to
forget that the act of making an
electric car does itself have a carbon
footprint and that's not often folded
into what it is people say they're
saving for having done so so yeah we got
to end it there Jason has been a delight
good to have you on this stuff thank you
for having me hey Jason Jason I really
appreciate it but we think we can't make
this the end of our conversations about
this because cars are endlessly
fascinating the past present and future
and that's where your your your your
head is up under the hood if not in the
hood and that's good enough for us all
right thank you so much really
appreciate you all having me you got it
all right Chuck Gary we got to call it
quits there it's no pleasure Neil
deGrasse Tyson here for a star talk
sports edition this one was up under the
hood how cars work basically uh with our
special guest Jason fenske I'm Neil
deGrasse Tyson you're personal
astrophysicistic keep looking up
[Music]